i'm not even going to talk about it but
let's let's let's pontificate
you know what no no no no no no no no no
no no no
no no where are you going let's
pontificate you're the one with that
you're no but you're going you're going
to bounce ideas off
that's what i'm saying so let's
pontificate let's pontification let's go
okay all right all right so here's my
first theory this is my first real talk
theory yeah okay i always said this
girls with shorter hair more they more
they bought that life more than girls
longer hair i would
tend to agree yeah i don't know why and
everyone's like
here's the right so so this is this is
what my thought process when i brought
broke this down right hair for women is
like a traditional sign of beauty
how you maintain your hair is like one
of the first indicators of beauty in our
side if you're willing to cut your hair
short and rebel against
societies like what they impose on women
in terms of what they need to look like
odds are you're probably more rebellious
in other ways yeah right generally you
you're probably not going to be a girl
who like likes
unless they're black the black girl is a
little bit different black girls and
their hair their relationship with hair
is a little bit different yes but if
they cut their hair
there could be a lot of reason so i'm
talking about if they're willing
not because of something that happened
no because bald but
black girls were like almost no hair is
like in some parts africa's just common
all is to say if you're willing to rebel
against that kind of beauty standards
odds are you're probably not inhibited
by
society's ideas of like what and like
intimacy should look like
right and so that's like the crossover i
made between short hair like
also it's been like kind of backed up
with my personal experiences but there's
no data to back this up
but generally what i've seen is like
short hair women tend to be a little bit
more adventurous so what does it have to
do with air dressers
all right well you know i mean who's
cutting the short hair and they ever
look at hairdresser's hair
ain't it funky ain't it wild ain't it
crazy
um okay so so
if you the professional hair up
thing
on your head odds are you definitely
bought that rebellious life
but you know i have the same theory with
like nurses nurses are freakier
fact i'm mad at that they're used to
watching people die they see everything
so odds are you know i mean a little bit
of period blood or whatever like
they're gonna be fine with it yeah every
nurse i've ever met
every nurse i've ever met what i mean
swallows facts
[Laughter]
i don't know about no male nurses male
nurses bang a lot though maybe
male nurses bang a lot media is
different
yeah yeah like yeah you're going to feel
differently about certain things
yeah they're used to wiping people's ass
cheeks and all that stuff you think
they're worried about a little semen on
their face
i'm mad about that it's different
occupations aren't just occupations like
what you have to have in terms of psyche
in order to go into them matters as well
you know i mean it takes a certain type
of person to be a skydiving instructor
not just anybody in the population would
just run up and do it you have to have
certain personality traits that
make you more accessible towards that
kind of profession in that same token
hairdressers i don't know what it is
uh just a little bit unstable to be fair
the same they're saying all her dresses
i'm sure they out there
i mean we got a couple unicorns every
now and then congratulations
yeah i think my hair is a unicorn yeah
it's also
this isn't pretty much like a woman only
business like they caddy is hell with
you
hey we just out here pontificating
pontificating
hey so you what's up if you enjoyed this
pontification hit that sub button
all right a lot of y'all watching not
subscribing pontificate with us in the
comments
and if you agreed or disagreed with any
of the points we raised
pontificate in the comments feel me yeah
be part of the uh alpha part kappa
that's us alpha pi kappa aye alpha pack
apple get the merch alpha pi kappa get
the merch if you're alpha pi capital
let's go that's us
if you didn't go to college if you
didn't go to university you don't have a
sorority or a fraternity
alpha pi capital is where to be it
stands for abba preach
comedy alpha pi kappa let's go
[Music]